moi j'attends les suivants l'ain dans ma
tête les en tant qu'enjeu prix à ils
disent quoi ils disent je tends tuto
m'entends tu vas match dubois mais eux
c'est comme si tu m'entends d'état
quelle merveille tant dans sa chérie
pinko entends tu arrêter les arrête de
rien en tout cas tu me rappelles moi
quand j'étais petit juteau tu sais je
devais avoir ton âge j'étais en train de
démontrer à nettoyer le sol de la maison
soudain j'ai entendu un truc dans ma
tête j'ai regardé autour de moi mais
papa nettoyer les toits l'état est alors
la vraie me dit bruni aurait mis mon
temps tu viens dehors bonnet alors je
suis sorti devant la porte de vince qui
avait fait c'est pas un petit cheval
c'est vrai qu'il parlait on a les coeurs
purs dans la famille c'est vrai qu'on
doit se le farcir à la maison toute la
journée sans sel famille qui en a
récupéré l'argent thriller n'y a pas
encore fait attendre sur toi
c'est encore pas tout y est